you go to these big cities and you will
see nothing but useless people and I'm
not trying to be a dick I'm not trying
they don't have to be useless but the
problem is many of them are listless and
purposeless and then they seek out
authoritarianism they support the worst
of the worst ideologies they actively
disrupt and Destroy so not that I agree
with that guy who's kind of a
nightmarish despot I do think it's
important to point out we have a
cultural problem in the U.S where we
have a large swath of people who don't
contribute anything but just drag the
system down combine that with the fact
that they also don't have a God right so
they they they get behind let's say it's
the work religion or the
environmentalist religion all these
different quasi pseudo-religions filling
the void and they have meaningless lives
it's a serious issue that we have to
address we have to find create
meaningful lives